des sites infestés de vidéos de viol de
scènes de triple pénétration anale de
torture ou encore de gang bang le
rapport du Haut Conseil à l'égalité fait
froid dans le dos il dresse un
terrifiant constat de la montée en
puissance de la violence sur les
plateformes pornographiques il s'agit
d'un massacre illégal à but lucratif le
mur dans différence qui a accompagné la
montée de la violence dans le porno est
absolument sidérant il faut sortir du
déni le HCE a mené une étude sur les
quatre principales plateformes sans
surprise 90% de ces millions de vidéos
dans lesquelles les femmes sont classées
par catégorie et par mots clés comporte
des violences physiques et sexuelles
stade ultime de la violence les sévices
physiques provoqués par une sexualité
ultra agressive sont devenues un genre à
part sans parler des vidéos
pedo-bornographiques le HCE en dénombre
1,3 millions des catégories très
recherchées le rapport insiste ce n'est
pas du cinéma tous ces actes ont des
répercussions réelles sur la santé
physique et mentale des personnes qui
les subissent signer des contrats avec
les producteurs de ses vidéos ni
changent rien selon le HCE qui les juge
nul juridiquement pire les autorités
sont totalement absentes le HCE a tenté
de signaler ses contenus à la plateforme
gouvernementale Pharos sans jamais
aucune réponse tous les contenus sont en
ligne zéro résultat ainsi le HCE
recommande de renforcer la capacité de
blocage de Pharos et pourquoi pas
d'avoir recours à l'intelligence
artificielle pour aider les enquêteurs à
effectuer ses contrôles les enjeux sont
immenses 2,3 millions de mineurs et 51%
des garçons de 12 13 ans consomment de
la pornographie c'est pourquoi le projet
de loi sur la régulation de l'espace
numérique prévoit le blocage
administratif sans accord d'un juge
décide pornographiques qui ne vérifient
pas l'âge de leurs utilisateurs une
avancée saluée par le HCE qui souhaite
des amendes allant jusqu'à 6% du chiffre
d'affaires de ces sites qui
n'interdisent pas leur contenu aux
mineurs
[Musique]